welcome to data vis deaf talk I'm your
host - cozy our today's guest is Mark
Soares mark is the manager of analytic
solution at click insight mark is also a
constant advocate for effective data
visualization and storytelling welcome
to the show thanks - it's good to be
here
so tell audience a little bit about
yourself what is your role at click
insight I am manager of our analytics
solutions team at click insight we are a
digital analytics consultancy we're also
a Google marketing platform partner and
my team is responsible for everything
from implementing analytics on a website
setting up Google tag manager creating
reports and dashboards often with Google
Data studio all the way to conducting
analysis and providing insights and
recommendations to our clients so you
could say we do the full stack of
digital analytics so you do a lot of
visualizations with data studio how do
you get started with it I was interested
in the area from the very beginning I
started using it about as early as it
was available and I think there were a
couple key benefits that I saw from very
early on that attracted me to the tool
one was the native integration with
Google Analytics the other main benefit
was the ease of sharing reports you can
share a link and the viewer can have
access to that report even without
logging in or downloading another
application and so for those two reasons
I was really attracted to data studio in
the first place and what's kept me
interested is all the updates and
enhancements that have been rolled out
over time to really make it a more
powerful reporting product so you
started with Google Analytics data and
you've been creating reports that you
share with your team members and your
clients but recently you've been using
videos for you for other purposes as
well for example you make almost
weekly contributions to the maker monday
contest so how do you get started with
that the whole practice of taking this
new data set every week and then
creating visualizations from that data
set makeover Monday is a community
project where every week there's a new
data set and visual posted with the idea
being that participants will take that
same data set and create an improved
version of the chart I started
participating in the group Monday even
before I started using Google data
studio and it was for the reason of
giving myself an opportunity to practice
and improve my data visualization skills
and by having that different chart a
different topic different type of data
set every week it provides a great
opportunity to practice and learn new
skills and with data studio by forcing
yourself to be in the tool regularly I
can keep my skills up to date and learn
some of the new features and
enhancements in the tool what if your
visualizations were also including the
makeover Monday book what is your
process for creating these
visualizations like how do you start
with the you said what is your process
for picking chart types or forms and
colors and like would it be the size of
everything where do you start how do you
go through the process and how do you
publish I think I have established a
pretty consistent process over the time
that I've been doing maker one day it
always starts with the data the data
sets usually provided in a spreadsheet
or CSV format when I'm using data studio
the first thing I do is create a data
source so that I have access to those
fields in data studio but before I jump
into creating any charts or visuals I
like to get to know the data set a bit
more I take a look at what fields are
available what dimensions and metrics
are in the data set and that often
requires reading some background
material and where that data comes from
often it's part of a larger report or it
was published as part of an article or
there's some more description about that
data set I think that's always important
to understand the data before you start
using it
to make sure that whatever
interpretations are going to make or
however you're going to tell the story
that it's consistent with what the data
actually represents once I get to know
the data I can go into creating some
charts in data studio I try to choose
the most appropriate chart for the
message that I would like to communicate
or the story that I want to tell
depending on whether I'm trying to show
all the data or focus on a particular
aspect of it I may make different
decisions about which charts are most
appropriate that often involves some
experimentation in the tool but once
I've decided on what the most
appropriate way is to visualize the data
I can then add to it with more visual
aspects of colors and fonts and layout
to really make a more polished final
product but I think that overall is the
process that I follow every week with
maker one day it is interesting that
when you're talking about the
visualization it's not just the chart
types you also have the data so you have
to have some domain knowledge about the
data then there's a storytelling part
like what story in the write what story
am I going to tell with this whole data
and then building it is based on that on
those two principles your approach to
data visualization seems to be very
unique you're using the common chart
types like bar charts and scatter plots
but then you're operating within the
same techniques and limitations but you
are coming up with something very unique
what inspires you like how do you get
inspiration for these unique approaches
to data visualization yeah I think I
draw inspiration from a lot of different
sources with many of the makeover Monday
visualizations that I've created I do
try to push the boundaries of what's
possible with the tool in particular the
data studio and try to show something
that perhaps people haven't seen before
or they didn't think was possible with
the tool but at the same time I always
try to respect the data and the story
that I'm trying to tell and make sure
that the message is clear
and then the visual doesn't get in the
way of that and in that context I have
drawn inspiration from people like
Edward Tufte and Stephen few who have
written a lot about the field of data
visualization and the principles of
communicating clearly with information I
also draw inspiration from others that
contribute to the visualization
community there are a lot of creative
and talented people that create and
share data visualizations and I think I
try and pull bits and pieces from
everything that I see and apply that in
my own work talking about community
you've built a number of community
visualizations and community connectors
for data studio
this committee is still young and
growing when you think about the
developer community and the prospects
that a new developer has in building
solutions with their studio I've done a
bunch of work with the community
connectors and visualizations creating
those custom components for a data
studio one thing I should clarify is
that I don't consider myself a developer
I can certainly code and I'm comfortable
with JavaScript and HTML and CSS but I'm
not a full-time developer nor have I
ever been a full-time developer but I
think that speaks to the ease with which
the custom components for data studio
can be created it doesn't require an
expert developer to be able to connect
to data sources or create custom
visualizations for data studio you do
need a bit of programming experience and
knowledge but I think what's more
important is to understand the structure
of the data how it would be used in a
report or dashboard and putting that
knowledge together I think gives anyone
a really good ability to create these
custom components right now the data vis
community around data studio is still
growing but I think because of the
framework that's in place it provides a
great opportunity for more developers to
get involved
and build have more custom components
would it be your favorite tip that you'd
give to our audience with data studio
that's a good question
I think or at least one of my favorite
tips is something that I do in my
makeover Monday visualizations very
frequently it's a rather simple thing
but I hide the page boundary what it
does is creates a very clean and crisp
look to your visualization the
background fills the screen and if you
go into full-screen mode then you really
have a true full screen experience so
it's something very simple but I think
it has a great impact on the final
visualization when would you use a pie
chart I think I may only use a pie chart
to explain to you why you shouldn't use
buy charts they're certainly not my
favorite chart type and there are many
reasons why other chart types are most
often better alright folks that's the
end of our show thanks again to mark for
being here if you want to see more
content on data studio make sure that
you subscribe to the GCP Channel and you
can always visit our developer site at
developers.google.com until the next
time keep making more visualizations
[Applause]